[ Indistinct conversations ]
♪♪
-Good luck.
-Let's do it.
-♪ Hey, hey-hey, hey! ♪
♪ Hey, hey-hey, hey! ♪♪
♪♪
-This is all our seats that
we're setting up here.
So, we've got -- We were
targeting about 64 seats.
We had to kill the front row,
but I think we're
still pretty close there.
So, we're setting up pods
that people will come in,
and those people
will get tested.
They all stay in their pod,
and they're more than
6 feet apart from everyone.
-Microphone -- do you want me to
bring it in a bit more or...
-Yeah, go ahead
and bring it over.
-There?
I'm pretty good.
I mean, obviously,
the shine is the only thing,
but you can
mat the top, right, or...
I talked to Higgins today.
It was ridiculous.
-Are we gonna do
the last line in here
or is he gonna leave
and I'll yell through the door?
-No, he's coming in
and him letting the door
close behind him.
I just wanted you to time
your line as much we can.
-Yeah, we'll make it sound,
audio-wise.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-It's not like you're distant.
-So, right now,
we're shooting the very end of
the at-home show, the last act.
Jimmy goes down the slide
in his house,
but then what's gonna happen is,
he's magically transported
to Studio 6A, where we've been
shooting all of our, you know,
shows since
the pandemic started.
What happens is, he moves
from 6A and wanders into 6B,
And this sort of, like,
previews what will be happening
next week, as
we're finally coming back to
our original studio.
-Jimmy!
-[ Gasps ] Higgins!
You've been here the whole time?
-You haven't checked
your texts or...
-I'm social distancing.
Show's been kind of quiet.
You know, no audience,
no Roots, no you.
-New York City's
starting to open back up.
They're letting us
come back to our old studio,
have an audience again.
-Whoa!
-It's time to go back.
I miss the studio.
-One step closer to normal.
-You got it?
-Yeah, I think so.
-Definitely, definitely.
-Good morning!
Thank you for everyone's work
to get into 6B today.
It's -- I know it's been an
insane amount of hustle and work
and everything with this
pandemic over the past year,
but I can't thank
everyone enough.
-Are we saying anything about
that we're happy to be back?
Saying anything about that or...
I'd like to be
the one person who was like,
"I wasn't gonna get the vaccine.
Then I heard about
that free doughnut."
So, I think cut 7A and do 7B.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah. You write that down.
Alright, dudes. Thank you.
-Alright.
-Thanks, guys.
-Whoo! We're back!
-Yeah!
-And now, here he is,
Jimmy Fallon!
-♪ Hey, hey-hey, hey! ♪
-Oh, wow.
-[ Laughs ]
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, he-e-e-y! ♪
-Hey, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
-Whoo!
-Oh, it feels good
to be back here.
Gosh, it feels good.
-We back, bitches!
-Alright!
-Yeah, snap!
Oh, snap!
-So, right now,
we are about to go into 6B,
and we're going to test out
a guest interview.
So I'm gonna stand in as
Eve Hewson.
And Jimmy's gonna be Jimmy,
and he's gonna interview me
as if I'm Eve.
And we're gonna test lighting.
We're gonna test sound,
camera angles, and all that,
and hopefully
it will all go great.
-Your brother has a band.
-Yes.
-And they consider you
to be the band mom.
-Band mom, yes.
-Yeah.
-They're really young.
-How young as a ballpark?
-Like between 5 and 7.
A couple of them are twins.
-What's the name of the band?
-That's The Imperials.
[ Both laugh ]
-The Imperials.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-They came up with that?
-Who came -- [ Laughs ]
-That would be J.J.
That would be J.J.
-That's J.J.
-Yeah.
-7 years old?
-7 years old, yeah.
-He's an old soul.
He loves The Imperials.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Questlove is here, everybody!
Kamal Gray! Tariq Trotter!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that --
standing ovation.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is wild,
'cause Seth Herzog,
who does a
great warm-up for us --
it's the first time
I've heard him do that
and get a crowd response,
like an "Ahh!", in a year.
That feels good, so I'm excited.
Here we go.
-How does it feel to be
the first guest back in 6B?
It -- I feel like
a million-dollar bill.
And I am flattered,
I am honored,
and I found out tonight that
I've been on "The Tonight Show"
more than any other guest.
-I'm so excited.
A little bit of nerves.
-It feels like
it's been two weeks.
-What's that?
-Feels like it's been
two weeks since we've been away.
-Two weeks since we've been --
I fell asleep, I woke up.
Suddenly, this.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, here we go.
♪♪
One day, one step closer.
Thank you, guys.
-♪ Get on up ♪
♪ Get on up ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Get on up ♪
♪♪
-We back!
-And now, here he is,
Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hey, hey-hey, hey! ♪
-What?!
-No, no!
-♪ Hey, hey-hey, hey! ♪
-Wow!
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, he-e-e-y! ♪
-Oh, my gosh.
Oh!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
Wow! Please, please, please!
Thank you very much.
Wow. Welcome, welcome,
welcome, everybody, to
"The Tonight Show."
You guys, we are --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are finally back home
in Studio 6B.
It is so good...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...to see this beautiful set
and this crowd right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness.
We have a great show!
I love you guys! I missed you!
Give it up for The Roots!
Come on!
-♪ Bass for your face, highs for
your eyes, don't blink ♪
-I want to come over quick
and just say hi to you
and thank you personally for
coming to the show.
I really appreciate this.
It feels great to come home
and it's just warm
and the sound is great.
I can't tell you
how much I missed this.
I really, really
missed it so much,
and I'm just
so grateful and thankful.
And, yeah, be safe, stay safe.
This is day one.
You guys were here.
Thank you very much.
I'll never forget it.
Thank you. I love you guys.
Thank you!